- "Is mayonnaise an
instrument?" by Mysterion.
I don't get it!
- [Male] Is mayonnaise an instrument?
I have no idea!
(laughing)
- Hey, guys!
I love interacting with you
so I thought I'd make a monthly segment
where I jump into the comments,
read the best ones,
have a few laughs, but also
answer your medical questions.
I'm going to get right into it.
And here. We. (high pitched noise)
- I think this boy's cheese
slid off his cracker.
- Anita Akway asks,
"Is water wet?"
Anita, water is inherently wet.
That's how wet is defined, in my opinion.
Weird question.
Sarai Ashby.
"Is it safe to crack your own neck?
(neck cracking)
"I heard that it's bad
but it feels super good."
Cracking your neck is probably
not a bad thing as long as
you're not doing some crazy
techniques on yourself.
Just the same way that cracking knuckles
doesn't cause arthritis,
this has been proven time and time again.
All that is are nitrogen
air bubbles escaping
from your joint space, nothing
dangerous is happening.
(bell dings)
Aditi T.
"Can you read and write Russian?"
I can read Russian probably
at a first grade level.
Don't judge me.
(laughing)
I came here when I was five
and I didn't get much training afterwards,
but I can't write Russian.
Casey Sweet.
"Do you know Hrithik
Roshan Bollywood actor,
"you act and look like him."
I don't know who that is, but
do I really look like him?
This guy?
No way.
"Thoughts on the Tide Pod epidemic?
"Have you had patients coming
in having consumed them?"
Tessa, I have not had patients coming
in who have consumed them.
I don't understand who is doing this.
It goes without saying
that Tide Pods are harmful,
just like I don't go around explaining
and lecturing people that
staples are not good to eat.
"Can you create a video
on decreasing fat around
"the abdominal area
for men? #gymstruggles"
Anthony I'm with you, a lot
of my patients are with you.
It's very hard to lose abdominal fat
but the one thing we have to keep in mind
is you cannot spot reduce.
You have to work on decreasing your entire
body's fat composition in
order to see improvements
in your abdominal area.
"Time for a haircut, Doc."
I agree!
Look, I got one!
(bell dings)
"What was you undergraduate degree?"
Well Kent, I did one of those
seven year combined programs
where I did a Bachelors in Science,
which was of Life Sciences,
and then a Doctorate of
Osteopathic Medicine.
So it's a BSDO degree,
seven years combined.
Only did three years of
undergraduate studies
and four years of med school.
"How often should you get a check up?"
Well Alexie, it really depends
on not only your age group,
it depends on your sex,
it depends what medical
conditions you have.
But I think it's a safe bet to say
that you should at least
see your doctor every year
to have a healthy conversation
and figure out when you should return.
"Is it good if someone
poops after every meal?"
Well first of all poonam, everybody poops.
It's a good book, you should check it out.
After every meal, it sounds excessive,
but if it's normal for you
and that's what you've
been doing your whole life,
it shouldn't be a problem
if everything else is fine.
Mandy K.
"Did you cut your lip?
"Or is that a cold sore?"
I know what video, The
Alcohol vs Exercise video.
And yes, that is a healing cold sore.
It's a herpes virus.
I took Valtrex, it went away.
By the way, a lot of you don't know this,
If you have an active herpes outbreak,
you could ask your doctor to write you
a prescription for Valtrex.
It'll shorten lifespan of your cold sore.
1154cle.
"What about sex vs exercise?
"I volunteer as tribute as
long as I get Doctor Mike."
What about sex vs exercise?
Sex can be exercise but you burn only
about 100 calories having sex.
And I love that radioactive ood wrote
that they're in for a threesome.
Thanks, radioactive ood.
I don't know what your username means.
What's ood?
- (laughing) I know right!
- K trian.
"There is research that said smoking
"can prevent us from Alzheimer's.
"Is it true?
"Can you discuss about the
pros and cons of cigarette
"and your recommendation."
My recommendation here is clear.
Don't smoke, there are no health benefits.
Whoever told you that smoking prevents
Alzheimer's disease is probably saying
that because you die
earlier when you smoke,
so you never get a chance to
develop Alzheimer's disease.
"How do I fall asleep faster
and how do I stay asleep?"
Well Edris, it depends.
I would need to ask you
a lot more questions
but one of the biggest
things that I see people
mess up when it comes to their sleep
is having their phone by their side.
Phones are a distraction
because you tend to look at them
and see that your friends
are up to some cool stuff
and you get jealous or
maybe you read a work email
and you get anxious and all that anxiety
and FOMO is horrible for your sleep.
But, the blue light that your phone emits
also hurts the melatonin,
sleep hormone in your brain,
which may not hurt how
fast you fall asleep
but it hurts the quality
of your sleep for sure.
That's been documented.
And next, look at your sleep environment.
Make sure it's cool in your room.
Make sure it's dark in your
room and quiet in your room.
And by quiet, it doesn't
mean completely silent,
it just means that if you have a noise,
make sure it's not like
(screaming)
- Ahh!
- Make sure it's like a white
noise that stays constant.
"Is there any medical reason
"for the legal drinking age?
"Obviously kids shouldn't
be downing bottles at five,
"but what's significant
from say, 18 to 21?"
Andrew, I think the reason that
the United States the legal
drinking age is 21 has a lot
to do with the religious nature
of the people that moved to
the United States from England.
But I also think that the
later that you start drinking
the better it is for your
mind because even at 18 or 21
your mind is still developing.
W. Rivera.
"Wow, this was annoying."
Rivera, I don't what video
you're talking about.
Man!
(laughing)
Sorry!
Marissa Buscemi.
"I would love to hear your
thoughts on soy products
"and whether it increases risk for cancer,
"especially breast cancer."
Marissa, great question.
Soy has phytoestrogens in it.
Phytoestrogens are
basically the plant form
of the natural estrogen that
you find in your own body.
Your body can react to
these phytoestrogens
and if you're predisposed
to developing a cancer,
specifically a breast cancer
that's estrogen sensitive,
eating a lot of soy
products or having a high
soy diet can speed up the
rate of you getting this
cancer and it can make it worse.
We don't have any answers or exact answers
on what everybody should eat but I think
keeping it in moderation, being smart,
and not overeating soy products is smart.
Saketh Rudraraju.
"I saw PS4 controllers in the background
"of a few your videos."
Very perceptive.
"What games do you play?"
I play on Play Station 4
Call of Duty World War II
and I play Overwatch.
If you want to add me, my
username is realdoctormike.
Add me, we'll play.
Sumru Büsra.
"How do you exercise?"
I have an interesting exercise routine
'cause I do all sorts of different things.
I like to keep it varied
so I'll play soccer,
I'll play basketball,
I'll go boxing,
but I'll also lift weights.
I'm a big fan of heavyweight lifting
to make sure that I stay strong,
that's very important to me.
And we've seen the best
results come from those
who weight train and cardio train,
so I always like to mix
up both of those routines.
"Doctor Mike, I have a question for you."
That's why we're doing this.
"Why do I faint after blood exam?
"The sight of blood doesn't bother me
"and I'm not afraid of needles."
Farah, it sounds like what you're having
is called a vasovagal response.
You, without even thinking about it,
your primitive brain
has a startling response
to getting poked and losing some blood.
It's not your frontal part of your brain
which makes some of your more
complicated decisions for you,
but your primitive brain starts
panicking that it saw blood,
that you're losing blood.
Your heart rate drops your blood pressure
and you don't get enough
blood flow to the brain
and when that happens,
you faint or you feel
like you're going to faint
and you're gonna blackout.
Not much you could do with that, about it,
but be cautious of standing up afterwards,
know that it could happen, and
take the proper precautions.
"I couldn't help but notice the pit sweat.
"You should really look
into Thompson Tees.
"They changed my life."
Chance, I don't know
what Thompson Tees are,
but I often wear scrubs so I don't know
if I can wear Thompson's Tees.
What I will say is that
my armpits do sweat a lot
and I am considering
getting Botox injections
into my armpits.
It's that serious and that
may be a future YouTube video,
so stay tuned!
Sanna Fatima.
"Can you please make a video
on CT scans, MRIs, ultrasounds.
"Are they really that dangerous to get?
"Can a CT scan actually lead to cancer?"
MRI scans and ultrasounds are relatively
benign Sanna, so you don't
have to worry about that.
CT scans do pose a health risk
because they do expose you
to unnecessary radiation.
How much of that radiation
actually leads to cancer
is a topic that's up for debate.
I have talked to some
radiologists who believe
that the risk is overstated
because they believe
that the type of radiation
that you get from CT scans
is not the same type of
radiation that we've studied
from Hiroshima and other times
when we use nuclear weapons,
because that's what we
use as our basis of what
is acceptable level of radiation
for the human body to
accept without health risks.
If you don't need a CT scan, don't get it.
If there's a significant health
benefit for you getting a CT
scan like figuring out whether
or not you have appendicitis
and you need emergency
surgery, yes, get the CT scan.
But if your stomach
hurts and you just want
to figure out what's going on,
maybe it's better to hangout a day or two
and see if the stomach pain
goes away and not get a CT scan.
Follow my logic there?
Eso Mohamed.
"What is your opinion about meditation?"
I love meditation.
I think we live in a
crazy, stressful world
where chronic stress is all around us
and our bodies are not meant
to handle chronic stress.
We can handle individual
stresses on a short-term
but chronic stress is
horrible and meditation
is a great way to break
out of chronic stress.
"What does the future
of medicine look like?"
A lot of individual,
personalized healthcare.
Meaning that, based on your genetics,
we're going to give you
a specific treatment.
For example, I can have
two patients come in
with the same illness
but treat them totally
different based on their genetics,
and I think that's totally awesome.
I also think there's
going to be an increase
in telemedicine which is
basically like Skyping your doctor
and I think that has a
use, granted limited use,
but there is definitely
a place in medicine
where we can use that and
the more technologically
savvy we all become, the more we can use
that soft of technology
to make us healthier.
"Hey Doc, you are losing your charm.
"Anyways, nothing in
this world is permanent."
I hope I'm not losing my charm, man!
That's mean!
This person doesn't even
have a username (laughs).
"Within the exercise category,
"which would you consider
the most beneficial
"for long-term health?"
I'm a huge fan of HIIT.
HIIT for the win.
It helps your resting heart rate,
it helps with heart rate variability,
it's good on your insulin levels,
and it's good for fat distribution.
So, I'm a fan of HIIT.
I swear by HIIT.
I practice by HIIT.
I recommend HIIT.
How many more times can I say HIIT before
you understand that I love HIIT?
HIIT.
Alrighty, I hope you enjoyed
the first installment
of this new series.
Go and watch some more
YouTube videos of mine.
Leave some comments because
I'm going to be looking
at the recent comments
and answering them in an upcoming video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat R&B music)